gaëtan du sausset bonjour ma fille lilou
bourial chi bonjour bonjour merci à tous
les deux d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour revenir sur l'actualité
politique de ces dernières heures et
notamment sur les modifications
apportées par le sénat en commission sur
le pass vaccinale à commencer par la
suppression et hier soir de la
possibilité pour les patrons de bars
cafés restaurants de vérifier l'identité
des détenteurs du pass alors est ce que
c'est une bonne chose selon vous
philippe bourrier si on commence avec
vous
écoutez d'abord bonjour tous mes voeux
aux téléspectateurs à la rédaction de
rtl jean profitons ce jour de 12 janvier
pour vous souhaiter à tous un joyeux
yennayer 2960 12 qui est le nouvel an
berbère comme je suppose que vous savez
tous
écoutés bien sûr c'est une bonne chose
les tenanciers d'établissements ne sont
pas des officiers de police judiciaire
ont demandé à des citoyens qui n'ont pas
la possibilité légale de pouvoir
contrôler l'identité de le faire enfin
quand je dis on c'est le gouvernement
actuel nous nous y sommes complètement
opposés à ce pas ce vaccinale
bien que nous incitons et nous invitons
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ne sont
pas encore vaccinés de se vacciner mais
m les responsables de ces établissements
dans des situations qui risquent d'être
conflictuelle les mettre dans des
positions qui ne sont pas les leurs au
quotidien puisque c'est le droit
administratif le contrôle d'identité et
en plus lorsqu'on est dans un état
républicain il ya le code napoléon qui
stipule que nous ne sommes pas obligés
d'avoir une telle entité dans l'hexagone
donc par conséquent on demande juste à
ce que la dignité la sécurité et le
droit soit respecté et détendue chaussée
vous aussi vous s'est levé aujourd'hui 7
un amendement du sénat sur le contrôle
d'identité
oui tout à fait je suis partage
entièrement l'avis et qui a été suivi de
mon collègue quand ces régionales
monsieur philippe pour iasi il est vrai
que si vous voulez cette espèce de
société du flicage de tous partout ce
que prône le gouvernement d' emmanuel
macron et qui fait suite derrière un
ensemble de mesures complètement
autoritaire arbitraire qui ont été
décidées de manière complètement
indépendante de la vie d'élus locaux de
responsables associatifs locaux qui
pourtant connaissent bien quels sont les
meilleurs moyens les meilleurs rouages
pour finalement appliqué un certain
nombre de mesures et obtenir par la même
occasion le consentement de la
population eh bien on voit que c'est une
espèce de tradition de la part des
manuels mâcon dans cette gestion de la
crise sanitaire qui ne se justifient
absolument pas et qui va mène à rebours
de la société que l'on peut désirer que
l'on peut vouloir à l'avenir pour la
france pour notre pays pour les
générations à venir
d'autant plus si vous voulez que ce pass
vaccinale de fêtes et une absolument
aucune utilité c'est pas seulement leur
assemblée nationale et marine le pen
vous savez qu'on a mené un combat
notamment législatives sont aussi un
combat et la politique ferme contre la
mise en place non seulement du pain
sanitaires mais aussi du pass vaccinale
c'est aussi l'avis de deux médecins
j'entends par exemple le médecin bernard
jomier qui vient nous expliquer que le
pass matinale n'aurait absolument aucun
impact sur la vague actuelle j'entends
encore les recommandations de l oms qui
nous explique qu'une une gestion de la
pandémie qui consisterait à la contrôler
en faisant des rappels de doses
systématique n'est absolument pas
envisageable bref j'espère que le
gouvernement entendra ses
recommandations de spécialistes
d'experts est aussi l'exaspération d'un
grand nombre de français et j'invite
évidemment tous ces français qui sont
opposés au pass vaccinale et attachés à
leur liberté et bien à s'exprimer contre
la politique sanitaire des macros lors
de l'élection présidentielle en haïti
alors philippe bourrier h et du coup on
fait quoi finalement si le pacs valve
steam passe vaccinale ne ne sert à rien
alors comment est-ce qu'on contrôle un
ce nombre de contaminations il est
encore plus de 300 milles 1 ces
dernières 24 heures comment on fait du
coup
visuellement on voit bien que ces
nouveaux variants l'eau micron et de
contrôle alors il ya des mesures
radicales qui est celle de dire pour
arrêter la pandémie et ben en conflit
tout le monde il y à d'autres mesures et
à ce moment là le gouvernement puisqu'il
nous dit que la vaccination c'est
l'alpha et l'oméga je pense que c'est
une des parties de la résolution du
problème mais si c'est la fin de la liga
pourquoi il manque de courage pour
remettre la vaccination obligatoire je
ne suis pas pour les accidents
obligatoire non je suis vacciné ma
famille est vaccinée c'est un choix
personnel je conserve qu'il faut que ça
reste un choix personnel et au vu des
nombreux mensonges qu'on a eu depuis le
début du gouvernement aux dieux
présentera public du premier ministre du
ministre de la santé il est normal que
les français et les françaises ont des
craintes ont des inquiétudes
personnellement moi j'ai je me suis
vacciné parce que j'ai été convaincu par
mon médecin traitant c'est lui qui m'a
convaincu de me vacciner j'avais des
craintes comme beaucoup de personnes qui
sont vaccinées aujourd'hui et c'est pas
le gouvernement qui m'a qui a levé ses
craintes au contraire à chaque fois
qu'il parle ils ont défilé craintes et
les peurs des gens donc il faut
sensibiliser il faut aller vers comme le
fait actuellement la croix rouge en
allant vers les plus démunis envers ceux
qui sont régulés qui n'ont pas la
formation et expliquer pourquoi il est
utile de se vacciner pour se monter jupe
en soie et protéger les autres mais
lorsque vous avez à longueur de temps
des gens qui vous racontent n'importe
quoi vous savez tout vous en être prenez
l'exemple de l'école en une semaine nous
avons eu trois protocoles sanitaires
différents trois en une semaine on est
chez les fous ben alors on a un
gouvernement d'amateurs qui n'a rien
anticipé et qui veux aujourd'hui mettre
une pression il l'a carrément dit le
président république veut pas prendre
ces propos parce qu'ils sont injurieux
envers nos compatriotes
mais le ministre de la santé a dit oui
le pass vaccinale c'est une obligation
vaccinale déguisé donc quand on a
affaire à des gens comme ça il est
normal d'avoir une réticence en face de
soi vous parliez l'école on va y revenir
mais avant
ce pass 1 vaccinale qui serait limitée
dans le temps selon lui le niveau de
l'épidémie et le taux de vaccination par
département regardez ce qu'a déclaré
hier le sénateur les républicains
philippe bas
nous ne voulons pas laisser le maintien
du pass vaccinale à la discrétion du
gouvernement qui avait imposé la date du
31 juillet il faut imposer certaines
conditions pour qu'il soit maintenu si
l'on maintient à un niveau national
inférieur à dix mille lits occupés il
faudra lever le pass vaccinale car la
pression qui pèse sur les hôpitaux sera
moindre a alors olivier ferrand lui
n'est pas d'accord en tout cas gaëtan du
sausset ça ça vous rassure ou pas cette
limitation dans le temps par rapport au
niveau de l'épidémie voulue par le sénat
si vous voulez je préfère évidemment
j'aurais et j'aurais préféré dans
l'idéal vous passez maximale n'est pas
lieu tout simplement maintenant
évidemment moins il le tiendra longtemps
mieux ce sera après évidemment permettez
moi d'avoir quand même quelques doutes
parce que bon déjà c'est très bien que
les républicains merci nous parle
aujourd'hui d'une limitation dans le
temps que ce soit au sénat ou à
l'assemblée nationale suivant les
consignes de leur candidate valérie
pécresse voteront le pass vaccinale donc
là elle s'ils ont manqué d'un courage
cruelle en 1re en matière de
responsabilité politique et d'opposition
politique à la gestion des crises
sanitaires par le gouvernement à des
manuels macron mais en plus de cela si
vous voulez et les républicains n'ayant
pas la majorité à l'assemblée cela veut
dire que institutionnellement c'est la
majorité qui est détenue aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement et le président de la
république emmanuel macron à l'assemblée
nationale qui décidera de l'avenir de ce
pass vaccinale il se trouve qu'à 20e en
hausse 10 et se passerait final on va le
mettre en place mauvard quatre mois
après on nous a expliqué hier nous a dit
non finalement ce sera jusqu'en juillet
et hier comme vous l'avez mentionné
olivier ferrand nous dit je n'envisage
pas de limitation dans le temps du pass
vaccinale il nous faudra peut-être le
garder tant qu'il y aura à nouveau des
variants 7e cette espèce d'exception de
société d'exception à locqueltas
vaccinale qui a quitté hier le passé
sanitaires qui sont l'ensemble des
mélèzes ces mesures liberticides qui
pèse énormément sur le quotidien il ya
une étude qui a été sorti ce sont les
chiffres d'ailleurs de santé publique
france qui nous lisent qu'il ya eu plus
de 40 % en un an de gestes suicidaires
ne l'a pas notamment des jeunes de moins
de 15 ans donc il faut cesser avec ces
mesures là puisque non seulement elle
s'aggrave la situation pour un grand
nombre de français mais en plus de ça
elle ne sont pas efficaces pas seul
signal on le rappelle c'est une immunité
le basque si un parent dans le vaccin
est une humilité individuel ce n'est pas
une immunité collective il faut que le
gouvernement l'entende il faut qu'ils
écoutent les responsables et les
scientifiques sur ce domaine là pour
essayer de faire en sorte que les
français puissent vivre à nouveau comme
avant alors justement sur vous parliez
vous parliez de cette jeunesse qui
souffre le sénat lui compte aller plus
loin que l'assemblée dans l'exemption du
pass vaccinable avec un pass limitée aux
plus de 18 ans et un pass sanitaire des
tests pour les 12 17 ans est-ce que
c'est du bon sens pour ne pas aggraver
la contrainte qui pèse aujourd'hui sur
les jeunes finalement philippe bou réagi
goûter jeux c'est pas du bon sens le bon
sens voudrait tout simplement qu'on
protège les femmes et des hommes les
plus vulnérables celles et ceux qui sont
fragiles il faudrait vous savez j'ai
parlé d'une mesure dès le départ de
cette pandémie en disant qu'il fallait
protéger celles et ceux et celles et
ceux qu'on ne veut pas voir partir
aujourd'hui on a des centres de vacances
désert en a des hôtels désert jeu j'en
appelle au gouvernement pour faire des
réquisitions et m les personnes bien sûr
sans la contrainte mais les protégeait
pas les mettre en marge de la société
mais que la société les protège et nous
laisser nous continuer à vie pour
continuer à faire fonctionner la société
continue à fonctionner l'économie parce
que sinon c'est pas possible on va pas
s'en sortir on s'en sortira jamais donc
à un moment donné où le gouvernement
pour les mesures nécessaires celle qu'on
attend d'un chef de l'état qui nous
annonce et qui nous a dit nous sommes en
guerre et mettre les moyens adéquat nous
avons des militaires en france qui
donneraient leur vie pour protéger leurs
compatriotes un militaire si vous lui
demandez d'assurer
le pas la garderie mais la garde des
enfants parce qu'on a beaucoup de
professeurs qui sont ko h est ce dû au
manque de détecteurs de co2 au monde de
plus charles pure leaf et 14h au monde
de masques ffp2 et bah ils le feront
parce que c'est leur mission de protéger
les français et les françaises
aujourd'hui nous avons un gouvernement
défaillant nous avons un ministre et je
pèse bien mes mots qui n'a pas arrêté de
nous mentir le ministre de la santé
rappelez-vous nous a dit des masques ça
ne sert à rien depuis quelques mois
après c'était 135 euros d amende pour
celles et ceux qui voudront refusé de le
porter et puis on nous met des
protocoles complètement différent qui
varient d'un mois à l'autre on nous dit
pas la vérité mais dites nous la vérité
et la vérité à l'esa protéger les plus
vulnérables
il faut les isoler il faut les mettre en
dehors de toute possibilité de
contamination et laissez nous vivre et
arrêter de vouloir mettre ces lois
liberticides qui est qui et qui oblige
bien sûr tout état de cause les gens de
se vacciner sinon ils n'ont plus de vie
sociale ils n'auront plus de travail ne
peuvent plus vivre et on voit
aujourd'hui qu'on est qualifiés on a été
à quelques mois de retard sur le modèle
américain où des gens peuvent perdre
leur boulot s'ils refusent de se faire
vacciner mais ça suffit s'il avait été
noir un menteur si enfin s'il n'avait
pas été un moteur du tout si nous avait
dit la vérité celle de la mesure qu'on
pensait pas eh ben il faut dire aux gens
on ne sait pas par précaution on va tous
se protéger et invités d'une manière
pédagogique les personnes à se vacciner
rappelez vous il ya un an le président
de la république le ministre de la santé
nous avait dit hors de question il n'y
aura jamais de passe or vaccinale il y a
un an ils nous ont menti et pour
conclure ils finissent par insulter nos
compatriotes ça suffit trop c'est trop
et effectivement je rejoins l'avis de de
gaëtan nous aurons des élections dans 90
jours je soutiens yannick jadot et je
vous invite à voter pour quelqu'un qui
ne mentiras jamais aux français et aux
françaises allant philippe bouriatie
vous évoquiez tout à l'heure la question
du protocole dans les écoles alors à la
fois le premier ministre et
le président de la république le
ministre de l'éducation également ont
répondu aux couacs et au aux accusations
regardez
c'est plus une adaptation qu'un
changement cette politique de test nous
la faisons évoluer pour que ce soit le
plus fluide possible
le protocole le même depuis septembre
simplement on a fait évoluer le curseur
alors gaëtan du sauzay on a fait évoluer
le curseur à explique jean michel
blanquer résultat si je puis dire des
enseignants et des parents d'élèves dans
la rue un demain pour manifester le
syndicat snuipp fsu prévoit d'ailleurs
la moitié des écoles fermées jeudi vous
les comprenez ses professeurs gaëtan du
sausset évidemment qu'on les comprend
s'il ya une incompréhension totale de
dire qu'au bout de deux ans de crise
sanitaire le gouvernement est encore une
fois dans l'impréparation encore une
fois dans l'incapacité de préparer des
protocoles clairs à en concertation avec
les responsables des établissements avec
la direction administrative avec les
enseignants avec les parents d'élèves
rires c'est quand même hallucinant
qu'ils sont incapables d'organiser tous
à sa chambre en plus encore une fois on
le rappelle le vaccin permet une
immunité indiqué ne permet pas une
immunité collective elle n'empêche pas
la transmission
la transmission du virus et donc comme
le disait philippe bourion chic c'est
vrai que les jeunes publics si vous
voulez ne sont pas forcément ciblés ou
directement dans le viseur de la
politique du gouvernement prioritaire
dans la politique du gouvernement avec
les l'ensemble de ces mesures qui ont
été décidées et pour compléter un peu ce
qui a été dit hier en amour il faut
savoir que la deuxième classe d'âge en
france la moins vacciner sont les plus
de 80 ans parce que ce sont des gens
qu'on n'est pas allé voir que le
gouvernement a refusé de mettre en place
une sorte de réserve sanitaire pour
aller à leur domicile directement les
appeler aller à leur rencontre pour leur
expliquer les bienfaits de la
vaccination pour des personnes d'un
certain âge c'est-à-dire ce depuis 80
ans ils sont aujourd'hui de sport sans
être non vaccinés la priorité du
gouvernement réduite ce public là avant
de sang contre justement aux plus jeunes
et de d'embêter tout le monde notamment
le milieu scolaire se soient enseignants
parents d'élèves et évidemment on pense
aux élèves alors dans l'actualité
politique également on en parlait avant
cette échéance la question des
parrainages 1 des mers pour la
présidentielle c'est une question qui
alimente le débat depuis 2010 est je le
rappelle le nom des élus qui parraine
les personnalités publiques sont
publiques et des candidats dénoncent des
pressions impossible sur les élus sans
anonymat alors selon vous est-ce qu'il
faut la changer cette règle des 500
parrainages philippe bories achi
écoutez un peu attendre je dis bien
entendre
qu'il faut et great et des candidatures
farfelues mais qui sommes-nous déjà pour
décider qui est farfelu et qui ne l'est
pas qui est dans le système qui est pas
dans le système qui est démocrate qui ne
l'est pas sa simple apparat question la
deuxième question on ne peut pas
concevoir dans une démocratie que des
candidats qui représente des français et
des françaises et qu'ils ont représenté
aux élections locales aux élections
régionales aux élections départementales
tu ne puisse pas se représenter non je
ne partage pas les valeurs et le
programme du rassemblement national mais
je considère que c'est antidémocratique
d'empêcher marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon ou bien eric zemmour de
pouvoir se présenter et de donner leur
vision et de représenter celles et ceux
qui adhèrent à leur vision effectivement
ce la levée d'anonymat ne pose pas de
problème par rapport à celles et ceux
qui sont comme moi encarté dans 20 dans
un parti politique qui sont loyal et
fidèle alors partie est alors candidat
mais nous avons beaucoup de maires et de
petits villages et de villes qui sont
sans étiquette et qui veulent avoir ce
consensus démocratique dans leur ville
et qui ne veulent pas créer de tensions
donc lever l'anonymat c'est eux les
exposés à des sanctions au sein de la
majorité auprès de leur population et
surtout les empêcher de pouvoir
respecter notre belle démocratie celle
de permettre à des gens qui ne pensent
pas comme nous de pouvoir représenter
des français et des françaises et puis
il y à un autre un autre sujet on
pourrait se dire et le faire de façon
assez rapidement de dire on met une
jauge la jauge c'est un million de
parrainage citoyen un million de
parrainage citoyen des électeurs et des
électrices inscrits sur les listes
électorales qui pourrait par enea
candidat ou une candidate
hélas si vous voulez éviter des
des candidats farfelus et bat
le la sélection se fait automatiquement
moi je condamne avec fermeté les propos
de madame anne hidalgo c'est juste
honteux et scandaleux ce cas là aussi il
nous reste juste une petite minute pour
conclure qu'on va entendre on va vous
entendre il a étendu ce sommet avant va
justement regardez ce qu'a dit anne
hidalgo
c'est la loi qui décide de qui participe
en fonction des parrainages s'ils ne les
ont pas c'est qu'ils ne méritent pas d'y
participer avec gaëtan du soleil nous
reste juste quelques minutes peut-être
votre réaction jusqu'aux vosges
justement à ces mots d'anne hidalgo
alors mais ses propos sont purement
scandaleux anne hidalgo profite d'une
boutique et celles du parti socialiste
et qui a bien qui profite à une
implantation locale et d'avoir
énormément d'élus particulièrement dans
les grandes villes est l'une des grandes
municipalités et qui lui permettent en
fait même en ayant en étant qualité de
-5% d'avoir plus de 1000 signatures où
on voit très bien que le système ne
fonctionne pas et il a su la position du
gouvernement est purement hypocrite
puisque quand vous avez un gabriel attal
porte parole du gouvernement qui vous
explique en 2010 est en effet ça a été
très compliqué pour les manuels macro et
sas et jouer jusqu'à la dernière minute
pour obtenir les 500 parrainages
maintenant qu'ils sont au pouvoir et qui
n'ont plus cette difficulté de ne pas
entendre justement que pour d'autres
élus dans d'autres personnalités
politiques ceci est plus compliqué c'est
absolument hypocrite de leur part je
rappelle quand même que non seulement de
ceux me créditer à plus de 10% et c'est
aussi le cas pour d'autres candidats
mais il y à des personnalités politiques
je pense notamment à georges et
kuzmanovic qui n'ont pas on va dire la
la même audience où la même notoriété
que marine le pen cas jean luc mélenchon
et qui eux sont des petits candidats que
nous dont on ne parle pas dans la
difficulté de la recherche et parrainage
et il faut aussi pour ça que nous
réclamons à minima que l'on lève
finalement maquereau et rétablisse
l'anomie l'anonymat pour les verts pour
les élus qui décident de parrainer les
candidats afin qu'ils ne soient pas les
victimes les sujets de pression locale
puisque
vous savez bien qu'en vous parrainez et
bien après vous pouvez avoir des
pressions de la part d'un responsable
départemental une collectivité de
communes etc qui va venir vous dire là
vous voyez vous avez parlé mais tu es
candidat c'était une erreur ça ne
partagent pas notre vision donc le
financement dont votre communal de soi
pour rénover la route pour rénover
l'église au délabrement et c est bien
vous ne l'obtiendrez pas cette
république finalement un peu mafieuse
des pressions locales etc n'a pas de
sens et c'est pour ça que me réclamant
au gouvernement de courage et de lever
haut et devrait établir pardon au moins
l'anonymat pour les maires les élus qui
décident des parents et bien un grand
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france merci à vous gaëtan
dû chausser conseiller régional
rassemblement national en ile de france
merci à vous philippe bou réagi
conseiller régional europe ecologie les
verts en ile de france également
eris